[Musique]
je vous présente monsieur link monsieur
link une créature gigantesque deux
mètres quarante deux ou trois cents
kilos je dirais plutôt autour de 285
kilos peu plus en fait sont les poils
qui me grossi avec thierry lhermitte et
eric judor sinon un peu oui suffit
d'ouvrir la fenêtre
le 17 avril à l'autre bout de la terre
y'avait cousin la quête de sa famille va
devenir une aventure absolument mythique
a vécu et macro mais vite vite il faut
lui faire du bouche à bouche
allez-y vous êtes l'homme de la
situation elle est quand même fait la
connaissance de monsieur link aller non
c'est moi vous êtes un peu lourd à mon
avis de foutaises aller de toutes vos
forces
je sais pas qui c'est la faute sur ce
coup là et on recommence